Prof: So Adam Smith.
And this is what I want to rush
quickly through.
His life--we don't really know
all that much about his life,
and it is not as colorful as
Jean Jacques Rousseau.
And then his major
contributions:
his theory of self-interest and
how self-interest is related to
the common good,
his labor theory of value,
his idea of distribution of
value between labor capital and
rent,
and finally (what is the most
often cited) with his theory of
the invisible hand.
So here it is, Adam Smith.
About his life,
he was born in 1723 in
Scotland, Kirkcaldy,
just outside of Edinburgh,
which is a beautiful city.
If you did not visit it yet,
I recommend that you do.
He entered the University of
Glasgow,
and interestingly at that time,
in the mid-eighteenth century,
for reasons which is beyond me,
next to Paris and in a way
London,
Edinburgh was the center of the
Scottish Enlightenment.
Then he also went to Oxford,
in Balliol College,
and in 1751 he was appointed at
the University of Glasgow as a--
Glasgow I would not recommend
as a tourist destination,
by the way
>
--he became a professor of
logic, and then he became a
professor of moral philosophy,
believe it or not.
Right?
The person who is known about
self-interest and the invisible
hand, his major first job was
professor of moral philosophy,
of ethics.
And, in 1759,
he published a book,
the book called The Theory
of Moral Sentiments,
which is a book on ethics.
Well we will see this is a big
issue, whether this book was
written out of expediency;
he wrote it just because he
wanted to justify that he's a
professor of moral philosophy
and he didn't really believe in
it because he was an economist,
a rational choice economist,
or was he really a moralist?
That's one of the big questions
I think what scholars on Adam
Smith are debating.
He traveled in Europe,
and this may have been a
turning point in his life.
He meets Voltaire and Quesnay,
a major economist of his time,
and other representatives of
French Enlightenment.
And French Enlightenment may
have actually influenced him and
pushed him, after the return of
Glasgow, to Kirkcaldy for
awhile;
he went back and that's where
he mainly wrote The Wealth of
Nations, and that's the most
important book.
But I think in order to
understand Adam Smith,
we have to come to terms with
the apparent tension between
The Theory of Moral
Sentiments and The Wealth
of Nations.
Is this the same author,
or these are two different
authors?
Is it the same theory,
or there are two different
theories offered to us?
And that's I think very
complicated.
He passed away in 1790.
Well I wanted to find you some
figures about--pictures about
his life.
The only thing what I could
find is a memorial on the site
where the house stood in
Kirkcaldy, where he wrote The
Wealth of Nations.
So it's not only Yale
University which is turning
buildings down;
even the British do turn all
buildings down,
even if they should not have
done so.
Right?
It would be so nice to visit
the house where The Wealth of
Nations was written.
But if you go to Kirkcaldy,
well you can visit that site
and to have a look.
Okay, so as I said,
Adam Smith seemed to have two
faces.
Regularly, normally today,
if you take economics classes,
he is presented as the person
who is advocating the
self-interested individual and a
committed theorist of the
self-regulating markets,
of the invisible hand-- as
little government as possible,
pursue just your self-interest,
and your self-interest will
lead to the common good.
So he is the sort of
inspiration for neoclassical
economics and rational choice
theory, and methodological
individualism,
to put it this way.
But he has this book,
The Theory of Moral
Sentiments,
in which he is writing about
sympathy as an important
motivation for human action.
And is this just a concession
to his job, or is there
something deep in him which also
saw the need for a helping hand
by the public authorities?
That's the big puzzle we have
to struggle with.
Well there are other people who
are more qualified to give you
the most authentic
interpretation of Smith.
I'll try to do my best. Okay?
Well and indeed The Wealth
of Nations looks like about
self-interested individuals and
the invisible hand.
I will present you enough
citations that you see it.
I will also show you why it is
possible.
Some of Smith's interpreters
will suggest that this is the
same Mill,
and in fact The Wealth of
Nations is just an extension
of The Theory of Moral
Sentiments,
rather than a contradiction to
it.
This is not the majority view.
Right?
Today, among economists in
particular, the majority view is
that you should not really pay
much attention to The Theory
of Moral Sentiments.
The Wealth of Nations
gives you the real source
and inspiration,
and this is what guides
neoclassical economics.
But you may find some
economists who disagree,
and you will find a number of
political philosophers who will
disagree and will say that this
is not the real Adam Smith who
is presented to you by
neoclassical economists.
And I don't want to take a
position in this.
I'm not sufficiently a Smith
scholar to be able to do so.
But I will present you the
argument both ways,
and you can make up your mind
where you stand on this.
So The Theory of Moral
Sentiments--just very
briefly what this is.
He does ask the central
question: How can we make moral
judgment?
How can we tell good from evil,
good for bad?
Well it's a very important
issue and question.
Many founding theorists of
modern social theory were
dealing with this.
The most important one,
we will talk about him at
great--in fifteen minutes--is
Frederick Nietzsche,
of course;
the genealogy of morals.
This is the central question:
Where does our conception of
good and evil come from?
But Adam Smith already here
asked this question,
and he said,
well "what's the
solution?"
That inside you there is an
inner person.
You are two people.
You act, and there is somebody
inside you who is watching you,
and that inside you will tell
you, "You did something
wrong;
that was not the right thing to
do."
And I think you should be able
to relate to this.
I can.
There is very often inner self,
in myself, which tells me that
was a mistake I did,
that was a foolish thing I did,
I should not have done so.
I know people who have a very
small impartial internal
spectator.
I know people who have very
great difficulties telling ever
that I made a mistake.
There are some people who
always blame others if things go
wrong.
Well I think they have a moral
problem, I would say.
So what about yourself?
You may have a moral problem if
your inner self never tells you
that you were wrong,
and you are always liking to
blame others if things went
wrong.
Then you have a problem,
an ethical problem;
at least this is Adam Smith's
argument.
Right?
Simple and persuasive.
Then he says--this is something
which is kind of inspired by
Hobbes--we are led by passion.
But now he is not emphasizing
fear.
He said, "also by
sympathy."
That's crucial,
and that's the crucial notion
for those who emphasize that in
fact Adam Smith in The Wealth
of Nations is the same Adam
Smith as in The Theory of
Moral Sentiments.
Because Adam Smith,
those who argue for one Adam
Smith rather than two Adam
Smiths,
say that he has a theory of
humans which is a sympathetic
theory of humans.
What drives us,
that we have sympathy for
others, other people's
sympathies, that in interacting
with others we are seeking other
people's sympathy.
Right?
We try to please people.
We want to impress people.
We want to have a reputation;
we want to have a good
reputation.
We want to act honorably.
So we are seeking sympathy.
We have a sympathy--we have an
understanding of other people's
human conditions--but we are
also expecting others to
understand us and value us.
Right?
And I think this is a very
important and intriguing idea,
which I will show,
try to show you later on,
may not be completely
inconsistent by the idea that
seeking self-interest is leading
to the common good.
Right?
Because indeed,
if self-interest implies that I
also want others to respect and
evaluate me,
the self-interest also implies
that I want to do good to
others.
This is in your self-interest,
that you can say at the end of
the day, "I am a good
person."
Then, in fact,
pursuing these self-interests
may not be all that different
from the common good because it
is inside you.
And this, I think,
is the way how he is being
read.
And he introduces the notion
for the first time of the
concept invisible hand in The
Theory of Moral Sentiments.
But here the invisible hand is
not what you are told Adam
Smith's theory of the invisible
hand is.
It's not the laissez-faire free
market.
It's the hand of God. Right?
God guides us to have a proper
balance between passion and
sympathy, and that is somehow
God's will, what we follow.
In fact, I will talk about this
later on.
A big deal is made out of Adam
Smith's theory of the invisible
hand.
The term, the word,
invisible hand,
the term, comes up three times
in his work.
Right?
And in each time he's using it
in a different meaning.
The way how we understand
invisible hand comes from a
section once,
in one sentence,
in The Wealth of
Nations.
And in fact it is specifically
about foreign trade and
international trade,
not about the role of the
government in domestic affairs,
but it's about free trade,
free international trade.
And this is the context in
which he's using the invisible
hand, as it is being interpreted
mostly today by Adam Smith
theorists.
Right?
So it's intriguing, isn't it?
Watch yourself when you are
coining a term because a term
occasionally can stick and then
it will be always attributed to
you,
even if you use it once in your
life.
Okay?
Well The Wealth of
Nations.
Well these are kind of the
Table of Contents.
He writes about the division of
labor and determination of
prices, accumulation of capital.
He writes about the evaluation
of societies:
hunting, raising agriculture,
and commercial societies.
He never used the term
capitalism;
modern economy was commercial
industrial society for him.
And then he offers a criticism
of mercantilism.
That's where he offers an
argument for free international
trade, and that's where he
introduces the notion of the
invisible hand.
And then something is on
taxation, what I will not talk
about.
So self-interest and the common
good;
one of the big issues we have
to discuss when we are faced
with Adam Smith.
And the arguments are if you
are interacting with each other,
do not expect benevolence.
Right?
Do not expect that somebody
else will be charitable to you.
There is also saying if you are
seeking
self-interest--specifically in
the citations I have;
for instance,
choosing your employment.
If you chose it rationally,
this will be in the common
good.
And I will try to explain why
you seeking self-interest in
finding the job which is best
for you is also the best for
society.
And then he says,
well the individuals are the
better judges of their own
interests than any statement or
lawgiver.
As little state as
possible--that's where it is
coming from, and we will see how
he argues the case.
So do not expect benevolence.
Okay, this is a very frequently
cited sentence from Adam Smith.
It's not in the text I assigned
for this course.
Well, "It is not the
benevolence of the butcher,
the brewer, or the baker that
we expect our dinner from,
but the very self-interest of
the butcher."
I go to the restaurant,
I do not expect the cook to
prepare me a good meal because I
need a good meal and I expect
the cook to like me.
Right?
I want him to cook a good meal
because then I will give a tip.
It is in the self-interest of
the waiter to serve me well and
serve me good food.
Otherwise I will not go back
again and I will not give a tip.
I will punish.
It is appealing to the
self-interest of the person for
whom I expect something,
and not is benevolence.
Well he said well we address
ourselves not to the humanity of
the people, not to their
self-love, but we want people to
take advantage of this.
This is an interesting issue,
by the way, even in everyday
life.
I'm sure in this room there are
people who think about this
differently.
Just to give you a very
personalized example.
My wife occasionally tells me,
"This person is not a good
friend of yours because this
person only calls you when that
person needs you."
And this does happen.
And my answer always is--and I
think in this way,
deep in my heart,
I'm a Smithian--"I don't
want friends,
I don't want anybody,
who do not see an advantage in
interacting with me.
I want people who actually act
out of self-interest seeking my
relationship.
It will be a bad relationship
if my friends always think that
it cost them to talk to me,
and they do not benefit from
the relationship with me."
Right?
I don't want my children just
to act out of love and sort of
be a pain in the neck for them.
Right?
I want my children to see that
having me as a father is
beneficial for them.
That's a good relationship.
Good relationships are always
based on self-interest.
You don't want to have a lover
who does not enjoy being your
lover.
Therefore you want people
acting out of self-interest.
And I think that's what he's
getting at here.
He said even the beggar--here
actually the citation says,
"The beggars are the ones
who are dependent only upon
benevolence."
But then he qualifies it,
he says, "But even for the
beggar it is not quite
true." Right?
The beggar will make some
tricks in which,
in fact, actually will appeal
to your self-interest,
that you are a charitable
person or what.
Now self-interest in employment.
He said well it's a very good
example.
He said when you are choosing
an occupation,
of course you want to have a
big job, you want to be
well-paid.
Right?
Those of you who are an
economics major,
you may want to have some nice
job at some brokerage firm in
Wall Street,
and with a Yale Bachelor's
Degree you would like to earn
$100,000.00 a year.
Right?
But why would you earn
$100,000.00?
Because the employer gets a lot
out of these skills what you get
out of Yale,
and therefore it will be in the
interest of the society that you
get the highest possible salary
because you make the greatest
contribution to the common good;
otherwise you would not be paid
that high.
Okay?
So therefore you will try to
find that occupation in which
you get the highest possible
reward,
but you will get only the
highest possible reward because
you make the utmost contribution
you can,
with your talent,
with your hard work,
and with your skills,
to the common good.
This is Adam Smith's argument.
It's a persuasive argument
actually.
Right?
Well I can go on;
it's not all that important.
Now this is very important too,
I find.
"Individuals are the
better judge of their own
interests than anybody
else." Right?
And well this is I think again
extremely important,
and I'm sure this classroom is
divided fifty/fifty percent
along these views.
Right?
He said well the individuals in
the local situations are simply
better judges to what is their
interest than any statement or
lawgiver.
Right?
People should judge for
themselves what they want and it
should not be a government which
imposes it on them.
Right?
This is a big debate right now,
for instance about the
healthcare insurance,
the healthcare reform.
Should we let it up to people
to decide whether they want to
have an insurance or not?
Should we expect people to be
individually responsible for
themselves, to take charge of
their life?
Or should it be the government,
or should it be a statesman,
the lawgiver,
the Congress who takes care of
people?
And he clearly takes a position
no, I think people are the best
judges of their feelings.
Now the labor theory of value.
And let me rush through of it.
This is important.
His point of departure comes
from John Locke,
as we have seen,
and it is leading directly to
Karl Marx.
Karl Marx radicalizes his
position, but the point of
departure is clearly Adam Smith.
And the argument about the
labor theory of value:
the labor is the measure of all
values.
And then he said,
"The whole produce belongs
to the labor."
And so far Marx completely
agrees with him;
and we will see when we will be
discussing Marx.
But then he departs from it
because he asks the question,
where does the profit and rent
come from?
Marx asked this question as
well, and he says exploitation;
those who earn profit exploit
the workers.
But Adam Smith has a different
view.
He says well those who will
lend capital and those who offer
land also deserve part of the
value.
Now let's see how this
contradiction can be resolved,
how he's dealing with this.
How can that all value is
created by labor and belongs to
the laborer,
and nevertheless the capitalist
pockets profit and the landowner
pockets rent for the land?
Then here this is very much
John Locke: "The value of
any commodity belongs to the
person who possesses it,
and if it is not for use or
consumption but exchange,
then the value of this
commodity is equal to the amount
of labor which has to be put
into this."
"Labor is therefore,"
he said,
"the real measure of the
exchangeable value of all
commodities."
Right?
Commodities can have a use
value, they can be very useful,
and they can have very little
labor in it, like fresh air;
though by now we know fresh air
needs quite a bit of labor too.
Right?
But the exchange,
how the exchange it,
will be guided,
according to Smith,
by labor.
Few people accept today the
labor theory of value;
Smith or Marx, no matter what.
And it belongs to the whole
laborer.
This is a very interesting
argument.
He said--and this is again John
Locke--
"The property of every man
is his own labor,
and therefore every value is
created by this labor,
and therefore it has to belong
to the person who owns the
labor."
"But."
he said, "this is true for
societies before capital is
being accumulated and before
land is privately owned."
Right?
So this is really an argument
for ancient societies,
without capital accumulation
and without private ownership of
the land.
In these conditions,
if there is no capital
accumulation and no private
ownership,
land is commonly owned,
then the whole produced labor
belongs to the laborer.
This is where he,
Marx, will depart dramatically
from Adam Smith.
So where does the profit and
rent come?
Well are capitalists simply
exploiting the workers?
He said, "No,
there is a distribution of
value between labor,
capital and rent."
Right?
And this is reasonable,
because the capitalist offers
capital in order--
in fact, advances capital to
the laborer,
takes risks with this
advancement of the capital,
supervises the labor
process--and therefore it should
claim some profit from capital;
otherwise would be a fool not
to advance its capital.
And the same goes for land
actually.
Landowners also will have to
give the land a site in which
production takes place,
and therefore they really
should be able to collect some
rent on this land.
Well finally the invisible hand.
There are three conceptions of
this--I briefly pointed this
out-- in The Theory of Moral
Sentiments.
He said this is really God
which gives us a sense of
sympathy and creates a balance
between passion,
desires, and hunger for more,
and self-restraint to respect
others and earn respect from
others.
Right?
And then, of course,
in The Wealth of
Nations, this appears to be
the free marketplace.
And then finally he had a
manuscript, History of
Astronomy,
and he said the invisible hand
is the hand of Jupiter;
the hand of Jupiter because
people,
as long as they are ignorant,
phenomena--
lightening for instance,
what they don't--
cannot explain--attribute to
the will of Jupiter.
Right?
Superstition;
the invisible hand is
superstition.
Okay?
So what is fun,
that three instances where the
notion of the invisible hand is
used,
in each case a different
meaning, and in none of the
cases exactly the same meaning
as we normally understand it.
Okay, I think I'm now moving
over to John Stuart Mill,
and to utilitarianism.
And he's a wonderful man and
makes a lot
of--<<technical
adjustment>>
Okay, so this is all about
utilitarianism and liberty,
and the long road from Jeremy
Bentham to John Stuart Mill.
Utilitarianism is a
fundamentally important
proposition.
It informs modern economic
theory, and it informs political
and social theories which are in
the kind of rational choice mode
of theorizing.
And the point of departure is
Bentham,
who in many ways is the
Founding Father of
utilitarianism,
though he never used the term,
and he influenced the life of
John Stuart Mill in a major way.
Mill's father was James Mill,
quite an intellectual.
He wrote a big three volume
history of India and the British
involvement in India.
He met Bentham in 1808 and he
fell in love with the theory of
utilitarianism,
and he asked him to supervise
the education of his son--what
he did.
And sort of poor John Stuart
Mill grew up under the influence
of a very strong father and a
very strong teacher.
And he invented the term,
John Stuart Mill,
the term utilitarianism in
1822, at a very young age.
Then he suffers a nervous
breakdown.
When you see what
utilitarianism is,
you will not wonder;
I mean, if you are really a
strict utilitarian,
difficult to survive without a
nervous breakdown.
All right, so what is Bentham's
theory?
He published a book,
The Principles of Morals and
Legislation,
in 1789, and there are some
very important claims in this
book.
And at first instance they
sound very reasonable,
but he may be pushing his luck
too far.
He said, "Well we are
created to seek pleasure and to
avoid pain,
and therefore if we can
minimize the pain and maximize
the pleasure,
that's when we achieve the
greatest happiness."
That's what will be called
utility.
Right?
So action is right if it is
leading to happiness.
Right?
We all want to be happy.
Okay, well and this can be
actually quantified.
The action is right,
morally right,
if the sum of pleasures minus
the sum of pains,
multiplied by the number of
persons affected by action is
positive.
Right?
Sounds reasonable, right?
If more people are happy in
society than unhappy,
then the society does as well
as it can.
Right?
That's really the argument.
Well there are a couple of
citations.
I don't want to dwell on this
too long.
I will put it on the web;
and it's not in the text I
require from you to read.
So, he said,
"The two big masters are
pain and pleasure";
somewhat a kind of similar
argument to Hobbes.
And he said,
"An action may be said to
be conformable with the
principle of utility when the
tendency is to augment
happiness,
and that is greater than to
diminish it."
And what is utility?
"Utility is that principle
which approves or disapproves a
reaction to augment or diminish
the happiness of the party whose
interest is in question."
Right?
This is a notion of utility
which is not all that far away
what economists are using,
even at this time.
Then here comes something what
I think nobody would accept now,
that's simply--he said,
"Well it's easy therefore
to calculate it."
Right?
And I already pointed this out,
you just count the number of
people who are happy and who
have pain,
and count the number of people
who are happy with it and have
pleasure,
and if more people have
pleasure, the sum total of
pleasure exceeds the sum total
of pains,
then you got the good society.
That's utilitarianism
à la Bentham.
Well John Stuart Mill--here he
is.
He was born in London.
He never attended school;
he was a lucky one.
But not necessarily all that
lucky because his teacher was
Bentham and John Mill,
who were tough people,
and he had to start learning
Latin and Greek when he was
three-years-old.
Well if there are anybody who
is Asian-American in the room,
Chinese, you may have to start
actually to learn how to read
and write in Chinese pretty
early.
But he did this with Latin and
Greek which to my mind is a big
easier than to learn all the
characters in Chinese.
Anyway, '22,
he established the Utilitarian
Society and invents the term
utilitarianism.
And then he suffers a nervous
breakdown;
I mean, two domineering people
in his life.
And then he also becomes very
sort of unhappy with the
expediency emphasis on
utilitarianism--
instrumentalism,
the coldness of the argument.
He's actually becoming--becomes
interested in poetry.
And then he meets Harriet
Taylor, a wonderful lady,
and a friendship,
a very close friendship is
formed.
Harriet Taylor was a fantastic
intellectual,
as far as we can judge;
one of the very first radical
feminists, and had a probably
extraordinary impact on the work
of John Stuart Mill.
If he would have been a real
feminist, he probably should
have put on his work Harriet
Taylor as a co-author;
she probably co-authored this
work.
I mean, she was married,
and this was an interesting
triangle which did develop.
I mean, in what way we don't
quite know, but they were
traveling together,
the threefold;
anyway, quite interesting.
What can I say?
Well '51, Mr. Taylor passes
away, and then John Stuart Mill
immediately marries Harriet
Taylor.
But unfortunately she has a
very short life and dies after a
short marriage.
So his undisturbed happiness,
to put it this way,
did not last very long,
and he died in '73 in Avignon.
Now about the work, briefly.
We'll be talking about three
pieces of work On
Liberty,
Utilitarianism.
I will not talk about his role
as a member of parliament where
actually he was one of the first
advocates for female suffrage,
which did not fly at that time,
and he even lost re-election
probably because he's advocating
voting rights for women.
And then he wrote,
'69, Subjection of
Women,
which in many ways is a
feminist book,
quite a radical feminist
book--a feminist book you can
rarely read from a man,
and especially not in 1869.
Okay, so what are his major
contributions?
He redefines utilitarianism.
Right?
As I said, he found it too cold.
He needed more sentiments.
Poetry-- Harriet Taylor,
gave him a sense of the world
which is richer in sentiments.
So he says, well there is
higher happiness.
Right?
There is a lower level of
happiness and there is a higher
level of happiness.
To have a good steak,
well it is pleasurable.
But to listen to the Ninth
Symphony of Beethoven,
it's greater happiness.
Right?
It's a higher level of
happiness when you hear the
concluding chorale of the Ninth
Symphony.
You are through the roof of
pleasure;
you have a higher level of
happiness than eating a nice
rare steak.
Right?
That's a higher level of
happiness.
And he said--and nobody argues
it more forcefully than him--
"Individual liberty is the
ultimate value,
and expediency"--and you
know what he means by
expediency,
that you get there by using the
least means and you maximize the
return--
"expediency cannot justify
intervention against individual
liberty."
A very interesting issue;
a very accurate,
a very up-to-date issue.
Just think about 9/11;
this is exactly the problem of
the 9/11--how much we can act
against individual liberty in
the name of expediency;
how much we are willing to
accept the limitations in
individual liberty?
And well we will see,
he said, expediency is not to
be ignored, but when the chips
come down, he said,
it is individual liberty.
He's a libertarian, right?
He is for the sanctity of the
liberty of the individual,
and he's the ultimate of
British individualism and the
sacredness of British
individualism.
And finally the third major
contribution.
He said women's legal situation
resembles those of slaves;
they are only worse off than
slaves are.
And he argues that in a very
articulate way.
And women should have equal
rights in jobs,
in public life,
the same kind of
education--total confrontation
with Jean Jacques Rousseau.
But he believes that in
marriage they can create a
friendship bond with males.
Well Harriet Freedman did not
quite agree with this.
Though she married twice,
she both times did it probably
reluctantly.
She did not believe in the
institution of the marriage,
though she did marry twice.
Okay, well let me see whether I
can still do this,
his stuff on utilitarianism,
and leave the rest for Tuesday.
I think I have some three more
minutes to go.
The main themes in the work
Utilitarianism is the
concept of higher happiness;
human beings have faculties for
more elevated appetites than
animals have.
Then he talks about justice and
legality.
It's a very complex issue,
but where he thinks that the
law is a more restrictive notion
than justice,
and he stands for the idea of
justice,
and shows some contradiction
between law and justice as such.
And then he talks about justice
and expediency--why justice
cannot be simply explained by
expediency.
Well again something which
speaks very much to the issues
which are on our mind.
Does expediency makes it just
that you torture an Al-Qaeda or
a prisoner,
or a suspected Al-Qaeda
prisoner, to get information out
because this way you save lives?
Some people will say,
"Yes, this makes it
just."
Others will say, "No,
it is unjust,
and therefore expediency--
you should not use expediency
that you get better information
out from torture."
Well I think I'll probably
leave it here and then we'll
continue it Tuesday.
And I hope it got you up in
speed--
utilitarianism and John Stuart
Mill,
and Adam Smith,
and you see how actually John
Stuart Mill and utilitarianism
radicalizes one stream of
thought which is in Adam Smith,
but Adam Smith is not quite
ready to go as far as Bentham
went,
and even not as far as John
Stuart Mill went.
Okay.